he gave me some extra motivation man in
the most kobe way he was like man i
think uh golden state's definitely gonna
win a championship this year
bro can you imagine kobe saying this bro
this is like my hero bro he's like yo i
think golden state's really
gonna win a championship this year brah
bro we had dinner bro this dude says
this [ __ ] to me man i'm looking at this
like bro what
i looked at him
straight in his eye
and i said no they're not
what are you talking about he said nah
man they got a really good team this
year i just feel like um you guys match
up well against them but i just feel
like they have a good chance that's it
they're not [ __ ] winning this year
we're gonna win this [ __ ]
like
we gonna win this [ __ ] what are you
talking about we we definitely match up
well and he was like man i mean steph is
killing this year i'm like man i don't
i'm not trying to hear about steph right
now bro like i respect shut up stuff but
i'm going smack at him